l'équipe de france elle est arrivée
aujourd'hui dans sa retraite près
d'aix-en-provence celle là même qui lui
avait porté bonheur en 1984 à la veille
de la demi-finale du championnat
d'europe qu'elle veut gagner les joueurs
français est invisible aujourd'hui
s'entraînait à huis clos
retour donc sur ces dernières 48 heures
pour prendre la température du moral et
de la forme de notre onze tricolore yens
la voix andré germain les bleus n'auront
sans doute pas le loisir ni le temps de
taper la petite balle pourtant depuis ce
matin jacques et ses boys sont logés ici
au moulin de verneuil à côté de salon de
provence
c'est dans ce havre de verdure de
fraîcheur et de calme qu'ils vont
préparer leur entrée dans la coupe du
monde à l'abri du chahut et des
attroupements que suscite leur venue
dans la région
je peux pas mieux espérer pour un
premier match pour un match ne va pas
d'ouverture mais pour me pour l'après
match de coupe du roi c'est fabuleux
le minot du quartier de la castellane
avait déjà donné rendez-vous à sa
famille à ses amis aux français ici même
au vélodrome il ya quelques mois
face à la norvège alors à 24 heures du
match la motivation est telle que les
mots lui manquent pour l'exprimer
je plains pas je peux pas dire ce que je
ressens quoi c'est beau les bleus
comptent sur les soixante mille
supporters du vélodrome demain et les
anciens joueurs marseillais s'attendent
à de chaleureuses retrouvailles
j'adore le football ils viennent au
stade pour voir du beau football mais
savons reconnaître aussi les les
qualités de battant d'un joueur dans moi
j'ai été très bien acceptée je garde que
de bons souvenirs de mon passage à
marseille
l'afrique du sud peut être l'unique bon
souvenir de guivarc'h avec l'équipe de
france il avait en effet inscrit il ya
huit mois contre elle son seul but à ce
jour avec les bleus alors l'afrique du
sud c'est lui qui en parle le mieux voir
les ordres à la télé notamment les
matches amicaux qu'ils ont disputés bah
ils ont un gros potentiel physique déjà
athlétique donc à nous d'essayer de bien
les contourner
ces duels qui vont faire la différence
grande confiance en nous grande
confiance